um so I'll be talking about machine
learning demos um and as Conrad
mentioned specifically the gradio
library which I'm one of the founders
and one of the developers behind um we
have a team at hugging face that works
on this library and uh kind of supports
it using kind of the hugging face
ecosystem and and we work closely with
the open source Community uh on the
library as well as on supporting these
demos so I'll talk about why I think
machine learning demos are are
particularly important and why like I've
chosen to work on that for the past few
years um and then the the majority of
this talk will actually be a pretty
Hands-On tutorial uh using gradio so if
you used gradio before we'll we'll dive
into some kind of features that maybe
you haven't used before and if you
haven't used it before that's completely
fine as well because we're starting from
the beginning anyways so all right let's
let's jump into it um so first of all I
I really think that we're actually at a
historic moment in the usage of machine
learning it used to be like just a
decade ago and and my background by the
way is in Academia so before starting
grade I was doing my PhD in at Stanford
in machine machine learning and even
just you know like less than a decade
ago machine learning models were
primarily used by other machine learning
Engineers like you know the idea that
you would train a machine learning model
and it would become widely used um by
ordinary people on their browser or
something like that was not not common
at all so it's mostly used by other
machine learning engineers and then you
had the rise of libraries like
Transformers and and kind of other high
level abstractions that made machine
learning models easier to use
particularly if you were a software
engineer okay so first you had like
machine learning engineers then maybe
you had know broader software Engineers
um and then now we're at a point where a
machine learning model um it'll go viral
on social media for example because
anyone can use it anyone can use it
through a GUI so we've seen many
examples of what many examples of that
you know things like Dolly mini stable
diffusion chat GPT all of these models
all of these machine learning models go
viral because they're actually you know
used and intended to be used by all of
us anyone really not you know just
machine learning Specialists but anyone
who can use a GUI or a browser in many
ways I think it parallels the rise of
personal Computing as well originally
you had the hackers the dedicated
engineers then you had kind of you know
sof you know kind of broader software
engineers and now we expect everyone uh
to be able to use a personal computer uh
we see something like that happening
with AI as well um and so why are
machine learning demo important why is
this change I think you know so good for
the field um I think demos are important
because of three big reasons one is
accessibility so we've already talked
about that so just increasing the number
of people who can actually use machine
learning the second thing is exposing
hidden biases um so this is something
that you know it's been talked a lot
about but I think it's still very very
important it's still very prevalent um
uh so like for example this here on the
right I'm showing the output of a
state-of-the-art machine learning image
classifier uh when you give it two sorts
of images okay the image on the left is
an image of the bride and typical
Western like cultural attire and if you
feed it into a machine learning model
it'll give you uh the following labels
it'll give you it'll tell you this is a
bride this is a dress this is a woman
you know reasonable kind of labels if
you feed it an image of a bride uh in
typical Pakistani or Indian attire I'm
from Pakistan it'll actually say things
like it's a performance ver a costume so
we're still struggling with these
questions of like cultural uh biases
present in machine learning models and
the reason they're so hard to kind of
root out is because you need lots and
lots of people to test out your machine
learning model and give feedback on
where it's working where it's not
working um and so that's where demos are
particularly important um because they
let everyone not just those with a
technical background try out your
machine learning model it's not always
reasonable to expect a techn like you
know the the machine learning model
developers to know everything about
every culture and all of the biases that
could be prevalent but if you release
your model um in a way that many people
can try out you know through these demos
you can get that feedback um and improve
your models performance um and then
finally I think this is a very important
one but one that isn't talked about as
much is that demos refocus researchers
on what's useful to users instead of
benchmarks okay so let me kind of
elaborate here a little bit more so a
lot of times uh we've seen that uh
machine learning the the field of
machine learning in the last like decade
at least maybe the last few decades has
been very Benchmark driven so someone
releases a data set and you try to build
a machine learning model that scores as
high as possible on that data set
unfortunately that's not always how
users what users care about right
there's this gap between you know real
world performance and kind of Benchmark
performance and in fact there's even a
gap between the kinds of tasks that
researchers care about versus what users
care about and demos can help you know
refocus researchers I'll just give a
quick example here so this here is a
very popular model lat consist
consistency model in the last uh few
weeks it it it's it's gone super popular
because it allows you to generate
machine learning image uh allow you
allows you to generate images using
models that are consistent thematically
and stylistically so that if you were
for example writing a story you could
reuse these images you know in different
uh you know poses and so on um and
different scenes so this is a super
important task but it's not
traditionally one that has like men
marks for like typically when you think
of image generation you think think of
benchmarks such as FID score and other
scores that generate how realistic the
image is that's fine but that doesn't
you know necessarily capture what what
users what users care about and so
releasing demos allows this feedback
loop between model developers between
demo developers and uh users who can
communicate to you know kind of model
developers this is actually you know
this is actually important to me uh this
is a task that's important to me let me
try it out let me see how well the model
is working on this
task so for all of those reasons I think
demos are very very important important
traditionally it's been hard to build a
demo for a machine learning model uh I
remember when we started grade a few
years ago we would talk to a lot of
model developers who actually really
wanted to show off their model that they
built with a web application but then
they found wait I need to learn not just
web hosting you know not just serving
the model efficiently you know flash
stalker web hosting all this kind of
stuff but then I also need to learn
front-end development in order to create
a good model JavaScript CSS HTML of
course um and so a lot of folks would be
like you know it's okay I'll move on to
the next uh project I have in mind we'll
just let this machine learning model uh
kind of um gather dust in a GitHub repo
somewhere um so that's what we wanted to
change um and that's why we started
gradio so gradio at its core lets you do
all of this like what I described
creating a machine learning demo or a
performant machine learning web app in
just a few lines of of python code the
core gradio class the one that is uh you
got to know if you're starting out with
gradio is what it's the gradio interface
class um and what the interf interface
class does is it um it lets you it
basically creates this guey for you for
any sort of inputoutput
model uh so in other words let's let's
think about a typical example let's say
you will build a model to generate
images based on a text prompt okay so
this is something like stable diffusion
or you know the recent playground uh V2
model that came out uh there's a lot of
you know there's a lot of models in this
uh vein now so what you would do with
gradio do interface is you would pass in
three parameters you would pass in a
function so a function is literally any
python function okay so the interface
kind of wraps around this function you
tell it what kind of inputs you want so
here we're saying that there's only a
single input it's a text box and then
you say what kind of output you want in
this case we have a single output which
is a gallery of
images and that's it okay so you just
those are the three required parameters
you can also pass in more than one input
and if you pass in more than one input
like a list of input components then
those get mapped to the arguments of
your parameter of your function so it's
pretty intuitive so if your function
tooken multiple parameters it will take
as we'll see in our hand on tutorial
just passing up a list of inputs and if
your function returned a list of output
you would have a list of uh output
components here and they would get
mapped directly all right so once you do
that um you can do this method here do
doq and this actually creates a very
performant uh very scalable queuing
system for for kind of that can handle
many many requests that are coming in um
as of gradio 4.0 this is optional
because this is the queue is built into
every uh gradio app so you might not see
this in in uh your kind of machine
learning demos but it's kind of there
implicitly and then finally you do
launch and if you want you can do share
equals through this is not required but
let's just pretend that it's not there
for a second that's all the lines of
code that you need so what like five six
lines of code in order to create a
performant guey for your application and
then you can start sharing this as well
so that's what share equals true does so
share equals true creates a public link
for anyone to try out your demo so no
need to worry about web hosting no need
to do anything you actually get a public
link that Maps directly to your computer
that you can share with your
collaborators you can share with your
colleagues you can share with you know
your family and they can try out your
machine learning model that you've built
so it's a very very cool way very low
friction way for anyone to try out your
machine learning
model okay um so we released grade you a
few years ago um uh and we're very
fortunate to see it has taken off in the
last uh uh couple of years at this point
we have more than 500,000 unique monthly
active developers building with gradio
they've built more than 15 million
gradio
applications um and the number of users
of these gradio applications actually
much much more so these are just the
folks that are building with gradio and
then they share their gradio
applications with other people um and so
we end up you know kind of seeing uh
gradio used in a lot of uh Cutting Edge
machine learning workflows uh but also
all sorts of other things like um
recently I was contacted by someone who
built a uh a website for their high
school science fair using gradio you
know we see all sorts of things from
like uh from cutting edge of machine
learning all the way down to things like
you know tax calculators to things like
um you know really any sort of time you
want to build a web application you can
you can consider gradio especially if
it's Mach you know model intensive or
data
intensive um of course there's a lot of
super popular gradio libraries um uh
gradio applications that are uh that are
used used you might have used them uh
you may have used them without knowing
that you're using gradio but things like
the automatic 111 Library as well as as
its variants uh like fukus um as well as
SD next all of these popular kind of
image generation libraries are built
with gradio um and then there's also
hugging face spaces which is a thing
that we've built at hugging face um so
hugging faes is kind of a central
platform for hosting machine learning
models data sets but also these demos um
and we've built uh hugging face spaces
as a place where you can actually host
your machine learning demos so once
you're ready and you want to share them
with other people and um you can you
know there's also discoverability
features there's also things like
discussion features so you know people
can comment and kind of discuss things
based on your machine learning model or
machine learning demo um and people can
open PLL requests against your demo as
well so it's kind of like a a
centralized place to kind of host your
machine learning demos um and it has a
very generous free tier as well so if
it's CPU based you don't have to pay
anything spaces will just host it for
free and if there's GPU based uh demos
you do you do pay a little bit based on
the uptime but stay tuned there's going
to be some exciting development uh for
that
soon um yeah and it's super easy to set
up a space if we have time we might end
up uh doing that as well as part of this
interactive
tutorial okay so with that what I'm
going to do is I'm going to change gears
a little bit um and we are going to
actually dive into writing code um and
so what I've done is I've prepared this
nice um uh collaborative tutorial here
so it's a collab notebook that you can
use to actually uh um run a lot of this
gradio code and it's designed
specifically for you know if you're
starting gradio from scratch but we'll
also cover some Advanced features so um
it'll give kind of a nice like
introduction to the kind of the gradio
ecosystem um so I'll come back to this
slide here real quickly uh so if you'd
like to follow along uh you can actually
type this URL into your browser it's
https
shorturl.at so shorturl.at
slash and this is important this all has
to be uppercase uppercase D J
T2 so I'll give maybe just a few seconds
for everyone to open this up in their
browser um we've also uh just added it
to the chat window the year perfect
thank
you all right so it's in the chat window
I'm hoping everyone has a chance to open
it up now and if you do it should open
up this collab notebook for you and I'm
just going to make sure that everyone
has permissions yeah everyone should
should have permissions to open
this okay all right so we're gonna start
off with installing gradio so just go
ahead and kind of skip over this
introductory material since we've
already kind of talked about this and go
to this first slide uh first line of uh
first code block rather and if you
haven't used collab notebooks before um
it's just you know interleaved code and
text and you can run any cell by just
doing control enter so if I go go ahead
and do control enter this or command
enter if you're on a Mac um it's it'll
go ahead and run this and you can see
it's installing gradio right now um and
it might ask you of you know you trust
this notebook you can say
yes and then it go ahead and install uh
gradio so it's super easy to install
gradio all you do is PIP install gradio
it's just a python package um even
though it does a lot of you know front
endd stuff as well at the end of the day
it's just a python package you can just
pip install it um You Might Get These
Warnings it's completely fine you could
ignore it for now um okay and then we'll
get
started so um we're going to start off
with gradio interface class so the
reason we're going to start off with the
interface class is it lets you build
demos very very fast now after this
we'll actually talk about what to do if
you want more flexibility and
customization but for now we'll start
with this interface class okay so first
of all go ahead and start by important
gradio then we're going to define a
function okay now this function is going
to be an image it's going to mock an
image classifier function okay so the
function is called classify image it
takes in an image and right now all it
does is just return this fixed set of
probabilities okay of course typically
this would come from your machine
learning model um but we'll get to that
later right now I just want to kind of
convey how gradio works because gradio
can wrap around any python function so
whether it's a machine learning model
you know happening inside of this
function or whether it's something else
it doesn't really matter so okay so then
now we actually write this you know
really just one line of of python it's
just formatted for multiple lines but
it's really just one line of python it's
a gradio
interface
okay it takes in a function called
classify image which is this function we
defined above and for the input we're
going to want an image component Okay so
we've specified this right now as a
string you can do it as a string or you
can do it as the gr. image class we'll
talk about what the difference is in
just a second but for convenience you
can just specify it as a string um and
for the output we want a label okay so
I'm actually just just going to jump to
the gradio docs for a second because I
think it's important to understand
what's going on here a little bit if you
go to the docs you'll see that gradio
comes in with more than 30 different
components so these components are
they're designed for common machine
learning workflows so we know a lot of
people work with audio for example we
know a lot of people work with chat Bots
a lot of people work with code um a lot
of people work with annotated images um
and so these are kind of the common uh
workflow common components that we've
built in to the workflow uh so the two
that that we're going to be using right
now our image so image is uh let's see
here image is here and label is here so
image and label so again I can either
specify them using
the the string here or I can do gr.
image um but for now we're just going to
specify using the string and you can see
and then I just do do launch that's it
and now I have
a a GUI that just got launched inside of
my gradio uh out of my collab notebook
so if you run this cell you'll see the
same thing pop up for you as well um and
so now I can drag and drop images into
here so let me go ahead and drag and
drop a cheetah image and you can see
here now I have my you know uh predict
my machine learning model you know my
mock machine learning model running in
the background I get my predictions back
and now showed in this kind of nice UI
here all
right oh sorry you're still on the
you're still on the gradio do yeah thank
you yeah thanks for that yeah so now
we're back at the collab notebook so I
ran this cell I ran this you know this
cell here I'll actually just do that
again just for uh kind of visibility so
this will launch this Gro application
here I'll go ahead and I'll drop this
and I have an image here that I've
uploaded you can also take an image from
your webcam or paste one from your
clipboard by clicking on this but we
just uploaded one here and I've run it
and now I get my predictions from my
fake machine learning model and I have
this nice UI that explains that does all
of that for
me okay all right so hopefully that
makes sense um I'm going to talk about
uh kind of the the key takeaways here
are you you need three ingredients for
your gradio interface you need a
function you need you need an input
component or components uh we'll see
that in a moment and you need an output
component or components so you can
either use the string shortcut or you
can use the component object itself so
when you use the component object it's
nice because you actually get a uh you
get the flexibility to customize that
component so for example instead of now
I can do the same thing but instead of
image I use gr. image and I pass in a
label okay in this in this case it's
going to be animal image okay I can also
pass in an output so for my label
component I can say only show the top
three classes that's all we should show
okay so um I'll do that again so now you
can see I have a little label here this
is animal image and again if I drop in
the same image my prediction now only
shows the top three classes so this can
be useful if for example you're doing
something like you know you're working
with imet with a thousand classes you
probably don't want to show all 10,000
Logics or 1,000 predictions
probabilities you probably just want to
show the top three uh or top five or
whatever it may be and you can customize
that okay so that's the grr interface
class those are the
requirements um there's also also uh
some additional parameters you can put
in so for example you can put in a title
which adds a title to the top of the UI
you can add a description which has a
description underneath the title and you
can add markdown or HTML here as well um
I won't go into that right now or maybe
we can just run this just to see what
that looks like
um so you can kind of see here there's a
title here there's a short description
uh there's Al an article parameter that
lets you put information underneath your
demo as well so it basically allows you
to customize um your demo very easily so
um the other kind of thing that's very
important is example inputs and this is
something that we've seen kind of is a
GameChanger when it comes to letting
people try out your demos very easily so
it's best to just maybe give this with
an example here so this um this is a
little bit of a slightly more complex
gradio demo um it's a calculator okay so
you put in a number here you put in an
operation you put in another number and
you submit this and you get kind of you
know an output here now what's
interesting here is that you're we still
have a single oh so we have a function
called calculator now it takes in three
inputs right three parameters so what we
do is we specify a component for each of
those inputs so first of all we have a
gr. number so number is another
component um and we want to give it a
default value so that's why we use the
the component itself
and that maps to the first parameter
then we pass in a radio button so we
have a radio button here um and that
passes to the second operation uh second
parameter which is Operation and we can
see like if operation is add or subtract
or multiply divide we do different
things so we pass in a gradio uh gradio
radio component um and again now we have
to use the class because we want to give
it specific choices to use and then
finally we have another number component
and which maps to the last parameter
here in this case we just use the string
shortcut I mean just for fun there's no
real reason we could have used gr.
number as well but just to kind of
change things up and then the output
here is always a number so we can we Al
also use a gr. number um but the cool
thing here is we we pass in examples so
examples show up as this table at the
bottom and they what they do is they
allow you to anyone to easily like
imagine you had same like um maybe you
had a an image classifier you don't want
necessarily people to have to find an
image on their computer to try out your
your your demo um you can you maybe want
to pre uh you want to provide a few
images they can just click on
immediately to kind of load the
image and um so this lets you kind of do
that very easily um and so uh you
basically you pass in examples which is
a list of lists and each of these
examples and the this kind of inner
lists corresponds to one of the input
parameters and so by clicking on that
list you go ahead and you kind of run
this and you kind of see this um it it
uh it does this as well and the other
reason examples can be very popular U
very powerful actually is because you
can cache them so if I type in Cache
examples equals true what it'll do
actually on launch let me go ahead and
do this right now so you can see it's
caching the example so what it's
actually doing it's running each of
these examples through my gradio demo
and pre and kind of saving the results
so if I click here and by the way you
can open this up on a new tab for easier
uh just to make it a little bit easier
to parse so now if I click on one of
these examples you'll see the results
automatically get populated in the
output so I don't have to run them
through my grade I don't have to click
this submit button this can be very
powerful especially if your machine
learning model takes a while to run and
you want to provide this nice experience
to users where they just click on an
image and immediately see the output uh
so yeah this is very commonly
used okay
um by the way um are there any questions
uh is there a way that people can ask uh
ask questions through the
chat um there is a way uh and there is
currently one question if you would like
to address it now or you could also do
it uh at the end of the keynote cool so
yeah I can I'm happy to take questions
now before we jump into kind of the next
topic oh cool perfect so there's a
question here from Sebastian I miss
realtime
processing uh and my conversation of
Voice without turn base buttons uh okay
yeah absolutely uh no so gradio does
support real-time uh voice interactions
uh so the way it works is we have a we
have stream we have support for
streaming audio um and I what I'm going
to do is I'm going to show you a demo
that uh that Ki which is a very cool
organization um built uh let me see if I
can find it Ki uh
speech um let me see chat uh okay cool
yeah so this is actually a demo uh that
was built by kokoi and if if you haven't
heard of koki before they um a lot
they're basically a open source Library
uh specifically for text generation so
they've released a variety of really
really really good uh text generation
models that are all open source um and
so uh this is cool so they built this
gradio demo um and by the way yeah their
their library is also super popular uh
more than 24,000 stars and all of that
um but what you can do is this is very
cool this is a chatbot so this is
actually very similar to what you're
describing Sebastian um you can actually
record from the microphone here I can
say hi there
um um what is the capital of
Egypt okay so let's see here okay so
here you kind of stop here so this is
sorry this is not real time okay so you
can see here but it captured my Cairo is
the capital of Egypt cool did you I
don't know if that audio got piped
through but that that um so what
happened was basically I recorded it got
sent here and then uh the chat got kind
of processed it and then we used
xtts uh the Ki text speech generation
model and it kind of responded with the
text and it spoke the answer as well so
this is actually possible so actually
this is not streaming so my bad this is
kind of recording and then you kind of
submit it but uh gradio does support
streaming as well so it actually be
really cool to actually build something
like this that's streaming um if you're
interested uh it's a little bit beyond
the scope of this tutorial but you can
search radio streaming audio
input and we have here for example real
time we have a guide here on realtime
speech recognition so it shows how to
use it with um trans with a speech
recognition model from Transformers
including streaming so what you could do
is you could basically all it's not too
complicated all you have to do is set
streaming equals true in the audio
component and you set live equal stre
interface um and so that allows you to
kind of do this kind of streaming work
and you kind of you can build a
streaming model and then what you could
do is you could like look for certain
stop words or certain gaps for a little
while and you know if the if the input
text hasn't changed then you can kind of
consider this as a processed request and
then you can you know do whatever you
want it would be really cool to build a
chatbot kind of like this uh kind of
like this cqui one but entirely based
and you know no turn based at all just
like based on based on kind of you know
talking to the chat bot so if you do end
up building that would be very very cool
to kind of you know I'd be happy to try
it out maybe spread the word
so cool thanks for that question
Sebastian um are there any other
questions before we jump forward okay so
there's a question
here
uh from ad okay how does gr oh yeah yeah
okay so great question so yeah so Gro
and streamlet uh streamlet is also a
fantastic Library um streamlet from kind
of and they both have their different
strengths uh streamlet is a little bit
different I think you know a lot of it
is kind of design designed for uh data
processing um things like charts and and
kind of dashboards um although you can
also use gradio for that um streamlet uh
can be used for machine learning demos
as well um but there a lot of things so
basically kind of the fundamental
difference I would say is that gradio is
optimized for building machine learning
demos um so what that means is for
example gradio comes in with a lot of
like these components that are super uh
relevant and super optimized for machine
learning demos things like the annotated
image component things you know other
things as well uh it also comes in with
this with this cue that helps you
understand especially when a lot of
people are using your machine learning
model it scales very very nicely it
tells users exactly when they should
expect to get their results back and so
on every gradio app can also be used as
an API so I'll talk about that in just a
second which is not the case for
streamlet apps so there's kind of like
different use Cas slightly different use
cases they're optimized for slightly
different things um yeah but yeah I
would suggest trying them both out uh
the other cool thing about gradio is it
uses the native python kind of runtime
and interpreter which means you can use
gradio everywhere you can use it in a
collap notebook you can use in a kaggle
notebook you can use gradio wherever you
already write python so yeah it's kind
of a a a nice
thing perfect cool are there any other
questions should be good okay yeah let's
let's go back to the uh let's go back to
the tutorial then okay so a couple of
cool other things that you can do with
the gradio um one of them is custom
theming okay so
um we can take the same gradio interface
that we built before but we can pass in
a theme okay and I'm going to pass in
this theme here I'll explain what this
means in just a second but this is a
theme here right now um G staff XKCD so
if I pass in this theme here you can see
the same grad application now looks kind
of like it was drawn by the X CD author
right so you have like all the font
that's different uh colors are a little
bit different um you can use this to
customize your gradio application quite
a bit so there's another one here called
uh John Smith
9982 small and pretty so we'll pass that
one instead so if I pass that one
instead now you can see the gradio
application uh looks a little bit
different um again functionally it's the
same thing but it just looks a little
bit different now this is another theme
that we built called cfoam again it's a
little bit different
um okay uh but again functionally it's
exactly the same thing uh you can get
very very creative with these themes um
and and if you are interested uh we
actually built a theme G gallery to let
people discover these themes very easily
so I'm going to go ahead and show kind
of that so this is the gradio theme
Gallery um and so this actually has a
bunch of popular themes that have been
built by the community um so this this
is the xkd xkcd theme it was built by
user called G staff on hugging face and
then they published it as the xkcd theme
um and so you can kind of see when you
click on this you get to see their uh
their theme a little bit more you get to
see uh um uh how different components
would look like in this theme and so on
so you can try out other people's themes
you can also build your own theme I'm
gonna oops lost that for a second I
share my screen again you can also build
your own themes and if you interested
you can read the themeing guide
here okay um and oh yeah and then we
actually we have a um we have an
interactive theme Builder that lets you
build and publish themes very easily so
if you're interested in that you can
just do import grgr grr. themes. Builder
so uh maybe I'll just run that in case
uh anyone wants to see what that looks
like so it's it itself is a gradio app
uh which is kind of nice so it'll run
just just fine and you can see here like
this is a theme Builder so you can set
things like you can set the kind of the
base theme and then you can kind of you
know change the colors so I want the
colors to be orange maybe you know do
various things and then once you're done
with it you can actually oops you can
actually uh view the code for your theme
uh or you can actually publish the theme
to the hugging face Hub and you can give
it a name and things like that so okay
so I'll take just a quick break again in
case there are questions because we're
going to change gears quite a bit after
this and we're going to talk about
blocks so are there any questions about
anything that we've talked about so far
with gradio specifically with gradio
interface okay looks like everyone is
good we're clear so we're going to
change um gears and we're going to talk
about gradio blocks okay so why are we
talking about blocks here so the
interface API is very convenient get it
lets you get started very quickly um but
there's often times things that you want
to do that you cannot like it's just not
possible to do with interface some
levels of customization you may want and
I'm not talking about custom themes here
I'm talking about custom you know uh you
want to change you want to uh group
together multiple related demos or you
want to change the layout of your demo
completely you know instead of having
all of the inputs on the left and the
outputs on the right uh or you want to
have a multi multi-step demo you know
you have the input of one thing becomes
the output of the next and the output of
the next becomes the input of the next
you know you want to be able to do
certain things or you want to be able to
hide certain things show certain things
you know you want to build a much more
complex demo um and that's where the
gradio blocks AP uh kind of API or the
gradio blocks interf the gradio blocks
class becomes very very useful um it is
basically a lowlevel API so interface is
a high level API blocks is a low-level
API that gives you like complete control
over how things are processed in your
gradio application how events are
processed how how things are laid out
and so on so let's take a look at a
quick example here so I have a gradio
demo here um I'm going to run it first
uh so if I run it you'll see initially
it looks very very similar to the demo I
had before okay and again I pass in an
image and it kind of makes a prediction
and you know it's just kind of running
through this fake model it's same thing
as before so why am I kind of you know
so what's the point of this I I'm just
going to show you how you would build
this with blocks and initially it's
going to seem like a lot more work but
we'll see why it becomes very very
useful because it gives you complete
control over how every single thing is
laid out so let let's go through an
example here so first of all we have our
function so this is just like it was
before okay then this is the key line
that you have to do with blocks so you
start a with statement okay so you say
with gradio oops Yeah with gradio blocks
as demo all right so with Gard blocks as
demo okay now everything that happens
inside of that with statement gets fed
get gets becomes part of your machine
learning demo okay so we'll start off by
writing some markdown so g. markdown is
a gradio markdown component you can pass
in whatever you want so here we pass in
a string here dog versus cat classifier
upload an image to detect if it's a dog
or a cat and we use this heading thing
for markdown and you can see it pops up
right here okay dog versus you know all
of this
stuff then we start a row so in a row
everything is laid out horizontally okay
then uh oh I don't think we have to do
all of this there's some extra stuff
here that's not strictly
necessary um I'm just GNA oh okay I see
what's happening here okay so I think we
don't
need oh I see what's happening okay
we'll just leave this as it is for now
okay so basically what's happening
there's a few layouts here and this is a
little bit confusing so what actually
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to just change this up a little bit I'm
going to just remove this um and I will
put this
here
okay and I'll explain what I'm doing in
just a
second okay so what I did was I built I
did a I I created two rows okay so
that's all in my demo in my blocks I
created two rows so the first row has an
image and a label so you can see it has
an image and a label all right so I drop
in an
image works like an like that and then
if I want to uh yeah and so I have an
image component and I have a label
component my second row has a clear
button has a button whose value is clear
and another button whose value is
classified and it's a primary button
meaning that it's going to look appear
like with this gold or with this orange
Hue whereas by default it appears with
the silverish or grayish Hue so you can
kind of see that here I have a clear
button and I have a and I have a
classified button so these you know
these four lines or so these five uh
maybe you know these handful of lines
they Define the layout of my gradio
blocks so it's pretty intuitive you know
things are laid out by in a column
format by default unless you put things
inside of a row in which they are laid
out as in a row or in a horizontal kind
of way so this lets you kind of control
the layout to your heart's desire
um you can also do things like put
things inside accordians so if you want
to put things inside an accordion you
can do something like
this so if I do this now I have an
accordion
here this accordion holds the buttons I
can collapse it I can open it you know
do things like that and then finally the
last thing that's important is you have
to Define your own events so events um
the way the blocks does events is is
super powerful because it lets you
define an event for almost any sort of
interaction you can imagine for any
component so here what we have is we're
having it say that hey if I upload an
image here okay if I upload an image and
then if I click the classify button if I
click the classify button this one the
classify button it should run the
classify image component and it should
take as input my image component so it
should take that whatever the value of
my image component is as input and it
should feed it to the label component as
output okay so that's exactly what
happens so I run this I click the
classify button it takes as input what
is here and it feeds an output to the to
the label component now what's cool is I
can change this I can say instead of
happening when the button is clict I can
get rid of this bun alog together and I
you know I'm going to just simplify this
grader demo a lot more I'm going to get
rid of all of the Buns
and I'm going to say and now you can see
you know it's showing this error because
button is not defined here and I'm going
to say hey if
input gets
changed so anytime input oh sorry that
does not not change change singular yeah
so input.
change run this function so what does
that mean that means that anytime the
value of this input component got gets
changed it should run the function so if
I upload an image it'll run the function
so I don't need any buttons at all my I
have a completely l live interactive you
know kind of uh uh gradio demo here so
you can attach any sort of events to any
sort of triggers so that's one of the
powerful things about
blocks so this is kind of a quick
introduction to blocks so are there any
questions
here okay Co we have a question that's a
little bit uh okay so it's about why we
chose V for gradio um yeah so it's a
good question um so spelt is actually
honestly a fantastic Front End Library
um so if anyone has used um kind of
react before or done kind of front-end
work I would suggest checking out zelt
um we used it for two big reasons uh
they both involve speed um first is the
speed of the gradio app itself so selt
is compiled so unlike react it doesn't
kind of you know you don't actually have
uh build this uh kind of front end uh
kind of reactive thing where you have to
where it manages kind of the reactive
State and things like that it's a
compiled language so you write zelt code
in this reactive style but then it gets
compiled into vanilla JavaScript which
means it's extremely fast okay it's
extremely fast and so one of the reasons
we switched from uh react to spelt so
initially we were on react in gradio 2.x
we switched on gradio 3.x to spelt um
and the reason was because of a because
of speed and the other reason actually
was speed of developer uh kind of the
learning curve so again uh we have a we
have a team of uh you know both
front-end and backend folks and
sometimes you know the gradio team like
for example myself I'm much better at
back end than front end but I've learned
spelt very very quickly because it's
very intuitive uh it's built on top of
kind of regular JavaScript with some
additional kind of modifiers and
additional syntax so if you kind of if
you know vanilla JavaScript learning
spelt is super fast and it's very
intuitive it's like it's just a
beautifully designed language um whereas
it took me much much longer to wrap my
head around react and kind of you know
for the new folks who've joined the
gradio team as well we've had new hires
since you know we've got acquired for
example they've all loved spelt they've
gone all gone up to speed very very
quickly so I can I would say like the
speed of kind of the the developer
learning curve as well as the speed of
the actual kind of runtime of the gradio
application um so great question by
Simon actually so how far would you say
that you can push gradio for use cases
that exceed the demo phase um actually
quite a bit and I'm going to talk about
that in just a little bit so let me come
back to that um I'm going to talk about
using gradio as an API so actually I'll
just quickly mention it now and then we
can come back to it in a little bit so
one of the cool things when whenever you
build a gradio application um is you get
an API for free so like say let's take a
look at this one here this this is the
the funky gradio application that I
built here you'll see at the bottom it
says use via API and so in addition to
the core gradio Library we've also
published two gradio client libraries
one in Python one in JavaScript or
typescript and this let you use these
gradio applications very very easily um
so for example here um so here I have
this gradio gradio uh application
running on this URL here so if you
wanted you could actually start querying
it
immediately uh right now using the
gradio client you could you know if you
were to install this and run this it
would literally run a query against this
application and You' get a prediction
back okay um so so uh I won't do that
right now I'll do that maybe in a little
bit but the point here is actually you
can actually build a gradio application
and then you can actually kind of um
launch it and you can keep it running
and you can use it programmatically as
an API um and it works quite well we
have a queue that scales to thousands of
requests um very performant we've
actually switched from using websockets
to ssse uh which has a a bunch of nice
advantages well it runs in much more
environment um so we've actually seen
people take gradio applications quite
far um very very popular ones so for
example you may have seen like the
illusion diffusion space um let me see
if I can pull it up illusion
diffusion um so this
is a gradio demo that was built by uh by
uh you know a Community member AP1 123
it's very cool you upload an image and
then you kind of you actually sorry you
upload a pattern and then you can
describe you know something that you
want and it generates a pattern with
that particular illusion baked into it
uh it was kind of viral on social media
a while back um but it has you know it's
super popular you know almost 3,000
likes here used very very frequently
there's a queuing system that kind of
manages everything um you know requests
coming in and allows it to scale kind of
very very high um so yeah um you can you
can use it uh for um production use
cases really um and if there's uh and
actually we've been thinking about this
a lot more recently uh being able to Pro
provide more visibility and analytics to
people who are using it in these kind of
production use cases so if that's
something you're interested in uh uh
please let us know um you can uh reach
out to us on Twitter or through the G
the GitHub repo and you know we're happy
to kind of help you uh get set up for
production use
cases and of course it's like everything
is open source so everything is
free okay cool I think those are uh oh
okay so there is one more question here
uh by Callan how much Computing time is
required to build a domain specific
application in real time in gradio um
that's super kind of uh specific to your
machine learning model it's hard to
speak generally so gradio gradio you
should think of it as kind of a rapper
over your machine learning model so it
doesn't add any sort of computing power
so whatever you would need um to
normally run it is is still the case and
gradio can manage how many people for
example can concurrently use your
machine learning model at the same time
so if you want it to be limited to just
one person using the machine learning
model that's completely fine
uh if you want multiple people to be
able to use it because you support that
with the computing power you can also
set that as well um and and actually
this goes back to the production use
case as well I won't talk about this for
the kind of just because it's a little
bit beyond the scope of this talk but
you have fine grain control over how
many people can run your machine
learning model at the same time as well
um this is something that we released in
gradio 4.0 so this is somewhat new but
um cool okay so we just have about 10
minutes left so the last thing that I'm
going to talk about
um well let's see here um yeah I think
maybe I'll talk about this uh here
because we've had a lot of questions
about real time and and iterative output
um so so sometimes machine learning
models they stream data back to the
client so you can think of a chatbot the
streaming data back you can think of an
image generation model that um uh that
that you know kind of is a multi-step
image generation model and you want to
show the intermediate steps to the users
the cool thing is gradio support set and
in a very python native way so in your
function instead of returning a value
you can yield a sequence of values and
if you yield a sequence of values they
show up in an iterative way back to the
front end that's it that's all you have
to do there's no literally no other
changes to your gradio application so
here what I'm going to do for example is
I'm going to count to three and so you
can see here it's kind of let me just
increase that maybe count
to uh six or something let's do count to
six okay so you you can see 0 1 2 3 4 5
it's just counting back and the way it's
working it's just I have an input that
gets fed into this count to n and then
just runs a for Loop until end and it
yields that value and it sleeps
obviously this is just a fake example uh
for Simplicity but the point is here you
could replace this with your own machine
learning model that's maybe iterating
over something and it's at every
iteration it yields the results back and
so we have people that have built very
cool real-time dashboards using this uh
you can do things like um build uh um uh
you know you know dashboards that
refresh every second you can do things
like build um yeah like streaming chat
Bots which we won't get into in this
talk but there's lots of Gro examples
for that um and yeah so oh maybe I'll
just show this example of a of a real
time uh dashboard maybe let's see if
it'll work here um yeah so this is an
example of of a real-time dashboard here
we can actually this re reading from
this uh Google spreadsheet and kind of
I'm showing this as a as a plot um and
it's refreshing every five seconds if we
wanted we could actually edit this uh
spreadsheet and you know it will update
the the the data in real time but um
just we'll uh just for the sake of time
we won't go through that um you can do a
lot more in gradio um you can chain
events together you can you can um you
can uh update the properties of
different component um I'll leave this
and I'll share you guys you all have
this access to this collab notebook so
you can run it on your own time and kind
of see how different things uh work the
last thing I do want to mention because
I I mentioned this is you can use things
programmatically so this is the actual
last thing promise um okay so uh so we
have this dog cat classifier that we
mentioned before and this is running so
you know again I can use this
programmatically sorry I can use this
via the UI you can see it's running here
but I can also see here it says here if
I want to use it via the the client I
should just do this so let me go ahead
and do that so I'm going to copy paste
this I'm going to paste it here and now
I have a gradal client that's connected
to this gradio application and now I can
do something like viw do viw API and
it'll tell me the data that's expected
by the application so it'll say Hey you
have this one endpoint here called
predict and it takes us parameters an
image and it returns a label and so now
I can actually do something like this I
can actually pass in a a prediction here
so I can pass this prediction um it's an
image here and I'm passing it through
this API and you can see I get uh
results back here uh you know dog with
confidence point9 cat with confidence
point1 the predicted label is dog so you
can use any sort of gradio application
in in production like
this okay so with that um I'll go ahead
and end um so if you're interested again
try out if you're interested in learning
more including for for example hosting
demos on hunging face spaces this call
AD notebook is yours I'll keep the
access open to anyone so try it out run
through it and you can kind of do that
if you have questions you can join our
Discord server or you can ask uh via
Twitter or our gradio GitHub repo as
well so let me see if I have links to
that uh oh yeah so we just released
radio 4.0 about a month ago so it has a
lot more flexibility so you can actually
build your own custom components you can
write a little bit of python and
JavaScript and you can and and then that
can now be a component that can be used
in any gradio application just like the
built-in ones you get all of the
benefits of using gradio components uh
including API access programmatic access
as well we've uh redesigned our media
components from scratch U made sure
everything is accessible to screen
readers and so on uh we use server side
events for everything and um there's a
lot more
customizability so yeah I think with
that I'll go ahead and and I will I will
end here so thank you everyone uh for
attending the talk or or listening to
the recording afterwards as well uh
bookmark the repo so if you click on gr.
De gr. deev it'll take you directly to
the GitHub repo and we ask if you want
to stay updated if you find this useful
just go ahead and install the repo um
and uh also uh Twitter is probably the
primary way that we communicate so uh if
you're interested in staying up toate
just follow us on Twitter the Twitter
handles uh super uh simple just at at
gradio so with that I'll go ahead and
I'll stop thank you again uh I think we
have a couple of minutes maybe if anyone
has any additional question uh oh cool
okay so um we have a lot of questions
here
uh okay so we have a question here
Chris okay so what's happening there is
you're probably trying so Christian has
a question about hosting gradio
application what you're probably doing
is you're actually using the share
equals true kind of link and what that
does it downloads a binary so that we
can create this share equals true so
we've made it super uh uh flexible now
including the possibility of Hosting
your own gradio share server um so kind
of reach out to us afterwards maybe
again on on on on the you can follow up
on the GitHub repo on this issue that
you flagged and I'll kind of I'll share
instructions on how how to set that up
uh basically it's just some operating
systems or some kind of uh usually
windows that tends to think that that
binary is antivirus there are ways to
get around that though uh will make that
easier uh Nishan had a question about
how does gr handle privacy concerns for
demos hosting um on spaces for example a
demo Builder publishing to spaces I
would like to ensure the demo users
handle is handled in an appropriate
manner okay yeah it's a great
question so Spaces by default they're
not P they don't have any sort of
persistent persistent storage um and so
what you can do is is um uh you know
there's no persistent story so anytime
that that space gets restarted all files
will get destroyed so by default it's
actually a relatively private uh kind of
you know privacy preserving thing to
host your gradio demos on Spaces uh if
you have more specific concerns uh
there's like other features that we
offer um as well um you know if you're
worried about GTP compliance and things
like that um there's something known as
the Enterprise Hub which kind of offers
uh some additional privacy and things
like that that you know you can look
into um kind of depends on what
specifically you're looking
for um so Angelos uh a great question
actually here um bidirectionality of
information between plot image
components and blocks yeah so uh with
image we actually have this so we have a
select event on image where if you click
on a event uh click on an image in an
image component that data gets sent uh
including where you've clicked so then
you can kind of do start doing
Interactive things and in fact if you
guys have heard of segment anything from
uh from meta they built a really cool
gradio demo where wherever you click
that part of the image gets segmented so
that's possible because of the select
event listener uh we currently don't
have that in the plot component just
because the plotting components are
relatively um they're like kind of
custom and like they support plot lead
they support different things like that
but gradio 4.0 comes with the ability to
create your own custom components and
Define your own uh events as well and
you can use the existing gradio
components as starting points so one
very cool thing you could do is you
could actually extend a gradio component
create your own custom component and
then publish it so that you or anyone
else can use it as
well so yeah thanks Angeles for that
question
um uh all right I think that's
everything and that's right uh on the
dot so thank you so much uh everyone for
joining it really been a pleasure
speaking with you and and great
questions
uh thank you again abubaker there's
actually one more question which is uh
is there any repos with lots of gradio
examples and use cases yeah absolutely
so the the gradio repo itself has a lot
so I'm going to go ahead and just share
my screen here
so so if you go on the gradio repo
you'll see here a folder called demo and
it has a ton of gradio demos for a lot
of different use cases so everything
from you know I don't know streaming
wave to Vex a streaming audio if you're
interested in that streaming ASR there
were a lot of questions about Auto
speech recognition and stuff like that
uh to kind of more basic demos like
reversing an audio file um you know and
things like that uh I will mention
probably the best so these are fine but
if you want to see like what people are
actually building uh my recommendation
would be to go on hugging face spaces
the cool thing about hugging face spaces
is you know you have uh so this was for
example a model that was released by
meta you have real demos that people are
building that are very popular and you
can see the source code for any of them
so just click on the files button you
can see the source code for everything
the full source code um so that's maybe
a lot let's try let's try this one here
so this is a cool demo that was built
automatic hallucination detection again
go on the files you can go on app.py and
you can see here typically uh the full
like gradio application so maybe for
getting started I would say uh use these
ones they're kind of simpler and they're
built by the gradio team but if you want
to see like if you're kind of you know
already familiar with the basics of
gradio you want to see what people are
actually building then you uh can go on
hugging face
spaces and I look forward to your gradio
application on hugging face spaces as
well